今天要给大家聊一个超级经典的婚约财产纠纷，
也就是那个让人头疼的彩礼纠纷，
这事儿呢，
发生在2024年4月4号，
离塘现在不算远，
他是从山东济宁市中级人民法院出来的一个判决，
而且是一个二审维持原判的精彩案例。
来我们看这是怎么个情况，
2022年12月的时候，
男女双方热热闹闹的办了一个进方仪式，
男方可是真的挺豪横的，
直接给女方送了十八万八的纪念礼，
女方父母当天就回给男方8000的红包。
订婚当天男方还特意买了五金首饰给女方啊，
足金的手镯、
项链、
挂坠、
手链、
戒指全型回了，
另外还有一部苹果手机和一枚价值不算太贵的钻戒。
恋爱的时候，
这两人甜甜蜜蜜的同居了。
2023年4月份，
男方父母给女方2万块钱的任家钱，
是女方上门，
男方父母给了任家钱，
然后男方的爷爷、
姑姑和老人一人给了女方1000块钱，
亲戚这边加起来给了3000块钱的任家钱，
不过这两人一直没有办结婚的仪式，
也没有去领结婚证，
突然在2023年11月份的时候，
女方就收到了法院的传票，
男方要求女方把所有。
走，
彩礼都还回来。
订婚时候的十八万八五金钻戒、
手机，
包括男方父母给的2万块钱任家钱，
还有男方的爷爷、
姑姑姥姥给的3000块钱任钱，
全部都算上了。
女方这下可始傻眼了，
心里特委屈，
因为觉得自己是被断崖式分手了，
不知道为什么就分手了，
精神上的情感上遭受了很大的打击和伤害，
所以在一审的时候，
女方不情愿还那么多，
还说男方的两万三的热门钱不对，
他就收到了1万块钱。
这个案子的关键在于男方给女方的这些东西里面到底哪些算做彩礼？
从一审判决咱们可以看出来一些小门道，
就十八万八的见面礼在订婚当天给了女方，
这肯定算错彩礼，
不过女方这边回给男方8000块钱，
所以这一笔彩礼的数额就变成了188000-8000=18万，
订婚当天男方给的五金首饰，
那也算是彩礼，
但是苹果手机却被当成了消耗品，
时间一长不值钱了，
就不算做彩礼了，
还有就是有一个有争议的钻戒，
大概7000多块钱，
判决书上是说，
因为男方没有拿出足够的证据来证明买钻戒的记录，
所以这个钻戒就没有被认定。
反过来说，
如果男。
方能够拿出证据证明自己确实买了这个钻戒，
钱确实送给了女方手里，
有这样的证据的话，
那么这个钻戒也要算进彩礼里面去。
男方父母给了2万块钱，
任家钱被法院认定为是彩礼，
但是男方的爷爷、
姑姑、
姥姥加起来给的那3000块钱就不算彩礼，
只能算是一般的赠与。
女方本来还不承认收到男方父母的2万块钱，
任家钱虽说自己只收了1万块钱，
但是法院从男女双方的微信聊天记录里面发现，
女方确实是收到了这2万块钱，
所以这2万块钱也妥妥的进了彩礼的金额里面。
那么这个案子彩礼到底有多少呢？
首先订婚当天的188000-8000的红包，
那就是18万，
再加上这个五金首饰，
还有男方父母给的2万块钱的任家钱，
所以彩礼的金额就是20万，
加上五金首饰，
确定了彩礼的范围之后，
下一个问题就是该还多少彩礼呢？
按照道理来说，
两个人既没有办理结婚的仪式，
也没有办结婚证，
那么就得全退回去。
但是咱们最高人民法院有一个关于彩礼纠纷适用法律若干问题的规定。
第6条说没有领证，
但是在一起生活过，
一方要求返还彩礼，
法院就得根据彩礼的使用情况，
嫁妆的使用情况，
共同生活和孕育的情况，
双方的过错等等因素，
结合当地的习俗来确定要不要还，
要还多少。
在这个案子里面，
女方没有怀孕之类的情况，
但是他们确实在一起共同生活过，
所以法官综合考虑了这俩人订婚，
婚约关系，
存续时间也不短，
还共同居住过，
交往的过程当中肯定会有花费啊，
再加上当地的习俗，
所以一审的法院判决就有酌情让女方还17万，
另外就礼金的首饰也通通的还回去。
这个案子咱们能总结出几个有意思的点，
第一呢，
男方的亲属朋友给女方的见面礼，
基于订婚或者过节给女方的这些财物，
那很难认定为是彩礼，
多半只能算是一般的赠与，
但是男方的父母给的大红包、
大额的见面礼就有可能认定为彩礼，
第二，
当今五金钻戒这些以结婚为目的给的价值比较大的首饰都能算做彩礼，
但是像手机、
平板电脑这些消费性的产品，
到最后价值贬损的厉害，
可能就不被认定为彩礼了。
第三，
双方。
同居和订婚对还彩礼还是有影响的，
女方得把聊天记录好好的保存下来，
比如说你发微信给他，
说你今天回家吃饭吗？
我给你做了什么，
什么好吃的这一类的聊天记录如果很多，
那是不是就侧面的能够说明你们俩已经同居了？
还有同居的时候一起买个东西出去看电影啊，
消费记录啊，
这些都能当做证据综合在一起去证明你们同居过，
在还彩礼的时候是要重点参考的。
第4，
女方说自己被断崖式分手，
精神受到了伤害，
想要少还一点彩礼，
这个法院是不认可的，
法律不保护恋爱分手带来的情感伤害，
分手是对方的权利，
当然也是女方的权利。
如果女方想要少还彩礼，
应该怎么做，
就得从钱花到哪里去了这个角度想办法，
比如，
女方在共同生活的过程当中，
付了房租、
水电、
物业费，
还经常买菜，
买各种生活用品、
衣服鞋袜，
这些经济上的支出可以作为少还彩礼的依据。
女方刚从情感上受到伤害，
想要少退彩礼钱，
这个路子是不对的。
好了，
今天这个彩艺案例就聊到这儿，
下次咱们再聊一个更有趣的彩礼案例，
拜拜。